hey 42 here social media is a dark and
seductive place that can swallow you
whole if you're not careful everywhere
you look someone's living a life that
seems far brighter and more colorful
than your own
it's amazing how much time you can spend
scrolling through photos of people you
met once at a wedding and haven't spoken
to since
and given how long most of us spend
using our phones in the loo these days
it's a miracle our friends and family
aren't pushing to have us medically
assessed
actually they probably haven't even
noticed because they're too busy on
their phones too
one of my favorite things about social
media are all those nauseating
inspirational quotes
the ones that teach you to enjoy the
journey not the destination or to
realize that today is a gift that's why
it's called the present then there's
dance like nobody's watching love like
you've never been hurt
definitely a contender for the most
overused quote ever pasted onto a beach
background
from what i can tell they're usually
posted by individuals who give a
particularly large dam about what other
people think and when they really want
to drive the point home they'll attach a
video of themselves dancing as if nobody
else is watching
presumably in the desperate hope that
millions of people will indeed watch
that's more ironic than ten thousand
spoons when all you need is a knife
okay that's not ironic at all but let's
not get started with that one where was
i ah yes
exhibitionist dancers and in this class
there was one man who stored head and
tiaras above the rest
henry cyril paget the fifth marcus of
anglesey also known as the dancing
marcus was a man truly ahead of his time
in an era when members of the british
aristocracy were expected to behave like
perfect stoic gentlemen with upper lips
so stiff you could chop onions on them
henry padgett was well
not that
no he was a dress wearing hip wriggling
blue steel posing duel encrusted
exhibitionist a real showman whose life
was as fascinating as it was short
this is a story of one of history's most
colourful forgotten characters a man who
defied every expectation of his class
and era in order to be exactly who he
wanted to be no matter the cost
henry was born on the 16th of june 1875
to the fourth marquess of anglesey and
his second wife blanche mary boyd
there were whispers that henry's
biological father was actually renowned
french actor
benoir constant coccola and considering
the love of the stage that would later
dominate henry's life
that seems plausible tragically when
henry was two years old his mother
passed away and he was sent to paris to
be raised in the cocker law household
further fueling those rumors about the
identity of his father
henry was to live in paris until the age
of eight when he returned to his
ancestral home on the island of anglesey
even at such a young age he was said to
be very different to his peers
and not just due to a love of smelly
cheese he'd picked up in france
a somewhat lonely childhood followed
spent mainly in the company of a nanny
and the many dogs which belong to the
estate before henry's stereotypical
aristocratic upbringing was completed
with surprise surprise and education at
eaton
in 1898 aged 23 henry ticked the next
box on the blue blood checklist by
marrying his cousin lillian chetwin
in october of the same year his father
passed away making henry the fifth
marquis of anglesey and one of the
wealthiest men in britain
[Music]
the family home and estates covered
around 30 000 acres in various parts of
the uk and we're valued at 535 000
pounds
somewhere north of 70 million pounds in
today's money
oh and there's also the small matter of
his annual income of approximately 120
000 pounds
16 million pounds today
just think about that for a moment
16 million pounds a year
that's more than 1.3 million pounds a
month
most people would struggle to get
through that kind of money even if they
weren't really trying but henry was
certainly not most people
in fact spending money may well have
been his true calling
because despite this almost unfathomable
wealth
in fewer than six years
he would be bankrupt
[Music]
at this point in the video i thought
about going through a hypothetical list
of all the things you could buy for that
squandered cash
but henry's real list of excessive
spending
doesn't really need any spicing up
for starters he bought the content of an
entire jewelry shop in paris for his new
wife whilst they run their honeymoon
the story goes that henry asked his
bride to pose wearing the jewels
and nothing else
kind of like every teenage boy's
favorite scene in titanic only without
the token artwork henry marvelled at the
glittering diamonds emeralds and
sapphires covering his wife's body
but before you get the wrong idea there
certainly weren't any pearl necklaces on
show
the marriage was apparently never
consummated and lilian requested its
annulment in 1900
freed from the constraints of matrimony
henry threw himself headlong into his
real passions theater and unadulterated
self-indulgence
the family chapel on the estate was
refurbished to become a 150-seat theater
called the gaiety and henry formed a
theater company poaching actors from
another touring group with promises of
substantially more pay
naturally henry cast himself as the lead
in pretty much every production
but hugging the spotlight wasn't quite
enough to satisfy his narcissistic
tendencies
he wanted to shine in every possible way
costumes for his lavish productions
caused eye-watering sums
apparently he'd never heard of costume
jewelry and he frequently commissioned
bespoke pieces from leading costumias
including a diamond-encrusted outfit for
a production of aladdin that cost 10 000
pounds more than 1.3 million pounds
today sadly that very same aladdin
costume was left unattended in a
changing room and
shock horror never seen again not one to
dwell on the negatives in life
henry simply had another one made
the stolen aladdin outfit wasn't the
only time henry was relieved of some of
his bling in 1901 his valet was charged
with theft pocketing over two million
pounds worth of henry's jewels
it's fair to say that henry was spending
money faster than mike tyson on a
cocaine bender
but he was so incredibly rich that to
bring about full-on bankruptcy
he was going to have to get creative
and oh my the lens henry would go to to
achieve self-imposed financial ruin
were insane
for starters he owned a fleet of
expensive motor cars one of which was
modified to pump perfume out of its
exhaust
yet another of his cars was modeled on a
luxury train carriage
complete with revolving chairs solid
silver fittings and cherubs carved into
the wood paneled ceiling
henry was delighted by all things
glittering and ostentatious so when he
decided he wanted a green ping-pong
jacket it naturally had to be made out
of emeralds
don't worry i had no idea a ping pong
jacket was a thing either considering
henry's flamboyant persona failed
marriage fabulous tastes and risque
outfits there was widespread speculation
about his sexuality not that henry
really gave a bedazzled hoot the more
people talked the more outrageous he
became during the intervals of his shows
he'd perform what was known as the
butterfly dance a habit that earned him
the title the dancing marquess the dance
was based on one made famous by american
actress louis fuller during which a
billowing silky gown would be used to
create movements reminiscent of a
butterfly spreading its wings and flying
of course there's no reason why a
straight man couldn't perform that dance
but this was the early 20th century and
things simply weren't done that way
it wasn't just whilst treading the
boards that henry wanted to stand out
off stage his dress sense was outrageous
often accessorized with a glamorously
groomed poodle
for some it seemed obvious henry was gay
but in truth there's no real evidence to
say he had any lovers men or women
some historians believe he was simply a
pure narcissist capable of only loving
himself
regardless he was certainly unafraid to
be himself and refused to be hemmed in
by the strict norms of victorian or
edwardian society
something that must have taken
incredible courage
don't forget homosexuality was very much
illegal in britain at the time
[Music]
after honing his on-stage craft by
entertaining the anglesey locals henry
took his fear to company on a three-year
tour across the uk and europe there
wasn't too much focus on financial
returns and it was more about putting on
the best shows ever
to his credit henry took things pretty
seriously and he was said to be an
accomplished actor the touring company
was made up of around 50 individuals
including actors an orchestra and
support workers
they travelled with their own specially
painted scenery and furniture as well as
elaborate costumes all of which was
transported in five large trucks
henry also employed a personal staff of
four and considering he made more
costume changes than beyonce
they probably worked harder than anyone
else in the company it's not hard to
imagine that the cost of running this
theater company coupled with henry's
lifestyle in general would eventually
lead to dire monetary consequences
initially henry started mortgaging his
properties to make ends meet but things
snowballed pretty quickly with his
unabated spending
by 1904 he'd accumulated debts of around
560 000 pounds over 72 million pounds
today and bankruptcy proceedings were
started
with trustees in charge of henry's
financial affairs
everything went under the hammer at a
series of auctions that would span 40
days
according to one newspaper it was the
most wonderful collection of clothing
ever sold
and judging by most of the surviving
pictures of henry it's hard to disagree
with that one
all told it took a good 40 days for the
auctioneers to work their way through
henry's many possessions
one whole day was needed just to sell
his huge collection of dogs
and it took more than several to work
through his otherworldly collection of
dressing gowns furs and over 900 silk
lined suits
for the most part the auction was a
roaring success henry's colossal
jewellery collection fetched 80 000
pounds alone
and by the time the hammer fell on the
final lot he was actually left in profit
which was provided for him in the form
of an annual pension of two thousand
pounds a year or about two hundred and
sixty thousand pounds in today's money
[Music]
now to the vast majority of us that
would still count as a huge fortune
more than enough to fund an extremely
affluent lifestyle
it doesn't buy you all that many emerald
ping-pong jackets though does it
according to one newspaper henry was so
unhappy with his new more modest
circumstances that he concocted a plan
to beat the house at the famous monte
carlo casino
a plan that you won't be surprised to
hear failed miserably
henry's final curtain call came in the
form of tb and after a drawn-out illness
he passed away in the monte carlo hotel
with his estranged wife by his side
without an heir or siblings the title of
marquess and what was left of the family
estate were passed on to henry's cousin
charles padgett
not that his family were in any way sad
to see henry go
almost without exception they were
deeply ashamed of henry
so much so that after his death they did
everything they could to erase him from
their history
destroying almost all of his personal
effects including his diaries letters
and any other traces of him
henry's theatre became a chapel again
and all the other changes he'd made to
the family's land and properties were
undone one by one
the national trust became the guardians
of the family home in the 1970s
and for a long time there were only a
few photocopied pictures of henry placed
near a toilet
but in 2017 an iconic picture of henry
was used on the cover of a book which
explored the national trust lgbt history
and the limelight returns to this
flamboyant character
thanks to his family's attempts to
strike henry from the history books
we're left with a bit of an enigma of a
man but henry is finally starting to get
some of the attention he craved in life
if you ask me the world is a better
place with crazy extravagant people in
it and i like to think that if henry was
alive today he'd be posting a
ridiculously cheesy picture of himself
on a beach at sunset complete with the
words if you're going to dance then make
sure everybody is watching and give them
a show they'll never forget and unlike
most people who post that crap henry
would actually have the lifestyle to
back it up
[Music]
thanks for watching